wow is that bad over there you know it
is not it is not it is not a right-wing
media narrative that San Francisco is
bad it is truly bad it is mouth the gape
you like the bear from the Sochi
Olympics thank you Russia
um but it is mouth agape uh oh my god
I've never seen anything like this broad
daylight
horror and uh you know
all the stores are leaving
and so I was really impressed we did
about 2 000 tickets
in a city in that condition
that's great I think that's I'm happy
with that I am happy with that
um I I think it's gonna be the next
American city to fall remember when
Detroit fell Detroit fell that's how you
knew people had given up on the country
um Detroit didn't have a police force
they didn't it was hard to get water to
certain parts of the set like the city
fell and we went
okay San Fran is going to be the next
city
to be completely abandoned which is sad
the food is amazing we went to a Chinese
restaurant
picked it at random and we went right
after the show some of the best Chinese
food you'll ever have
um
it's an important city culturally it's
an important city
um in a lot of different respects you
know uh economically it was very
important to Northern California uh a
lot of the uh you know tech companies
originated in San Francisco
um but now it is it is as it is as bad
as it's gonna get I don't know how it
gets worse
I don't I don't know what could happen
to make it worse
um
and uh you know there's nothing to do
except go in and and then leave
immediately but it is fun if you like a
little bit of disaster tourism which I
like I think and you got to be sick
[__] to enjoy it
but if you're watching this you are part
of the fun of the next 30 Years in
America will be kind of a disaster
tourism going to the worst places there
will be many
where you have fentanyl addicts in the
street I saw a guy in San Fran he was
[__] and jabbing himself with a
needle in his leg
and you know I gotta be honest with you
listen is it sad yes but
you have to make the best of it and I do
believe that like part of the next
you know the next
phase of tourism in America will be like
it's not only going to be like let's see
the you know Yellowstone National Park
it's gonna be like let's see the city
that everybody's fleeing let's go to the
place that every and it's kind of fun
and you get into the Chinese restaurant
you're like looking outside you're like
what's going on and then you see like a
the homeless person and they're like
kind of got a thing over them and
they're draped in like a cape but
they're still on the motorized chair and
they just go by and then you're like
you're hitting the guy next to you
you're like look at that look at that
we're in it we're in it it's fun it's a
little fun and you have to embrace it
and I think out of that San Francisco's
next move it's like we're a ghoulish
attraction it's become a ghoulish
attraction and it's a little fun you
know because the food is great and it's
fun but you're always kind of alert I
mean why are these faggity Americans
going to escape rooms why do they
manufacturing danger for their sad
Suburban meaningless lives go to the
cities we've ruined go to the cities
that we've destroyed with with our
politics go to the places where we've
crushed the human spirit and enjoy them
for what they are I mean isn't that
better than doing a dumb escape room or
doing something stupid these people go
to haunted houses
haunted heyra you don't need any of that
you're an adult
adults should go to these go to Flint
Michigan and the here's actually why you
can't get mad at me because I know
people are getting maybe like they're
like oh this is actually not tasteful it
is and I'll tell you why
gawking at the human
waste because it's just a waste of
potential of Life whatever you want to
say right I mean it's not I'm not into
they are human beings and I'm not
trivializing the problems what I'm
saying is gawking at them in their
moment of need actually helps them
because the tourism money they need
if you go to Flint Michigan to gawk at
the hell you're filling up the hotels
you're filling up the restaurants it's
actually good for them it's actually not
what you're thinking it's the other way
so all these people that are like well
this sounds actually pretty heartless so
you're telling me I should go with my
Suburban you know comfortably middle
class group of friends and we should go
do a night or two in a disaster area
like Sanford yes yes because the tourism
dollar helps them
and it is a little fun it's fun because
you know this is going to sound horrible
at a certain point of drug addiction and
I've been a drug addict you you really
are not a person at that point you're
not a person at that point it's really
true no one wants to talk about this but
I'll do it because we have a beautiful
set and we have the Sochi bear provided
by Russia now you're not I've been there
I've been in the depths of a drug
addiction meaning I was a uh you know
and I think maybe the worst of it was
when I was in my early 20s I was
directionless I was working in finance
and I was doing drugs all the time
snorting cocaine drinking smoking weed
taking pills I was not a human being at
that point
because I was you become the drug you
just become this thing that wants drugs
and you want to feel better and and you
exist in a binary state of being either
high or anxiety ridden trying to get
drugs those are the only two it's a
binary existence
um and those drugs pale in comparison to
fentanyl or uh crocodile or whatever the
hell's going on in San Francisco crank
dope or whatever the new things are you
can't even keep up with them so I'm not
saying that these people at one point
weren't human beings and I'm not saying
there isn't a human being down deep in
there but at this point they may as well
be animatronic you know it's a small
world it's a small world after all at
this point they may as well be
animatronic It's a Small World there
because they're not they're making
shapes with their own bodies that no
one's ever seen before the the way they
can bend and shift and the things
they're doing the way their eyes are
daughting around they're wearing this
and it's really amazing the
post-apocalyptic stuff they're wearing
they're doing big hats and it's very
black and large capes and I like it I
think it's actually good it's very and
they're on the motorized scooter and I'm
gonna send you I'm gonna send you and I
want you to bring this up and I want you
to close up on this woman and I don't
know if it's a woman and it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter and again I'm
not trying because this
this helps them do you get it are you
with me on this going and gawking going
and giggling going and going oh my God
it helps them I'm telling you and I know
it doesn't seem like it does I am but it
does it does it does it does and I don't
know the problem so here I'm sending
this to the good producer and now I want
you to put this up on the screen for
everyone to see because I want you
to basically let and we're going to
close up we're doing close up on this
person here and this woman now again
this and people are going to get I I
already see people going to get angry
with me but that doesn't I I can't not
do what I do here because I'm making
sense now I want you I just sent you the
close-up version too the next version is
going to be close up I'm sending now
okay you can do it yourself get in there
get it on her tight get it on her tight
okay listen
when I tell you
this is one of the better looking people
in San Francisco right now
listen they go by and they Zip by you
and and it's fun because
by
listen to me I know that I I know that
this isn't but it's true why are people
why are you mad at me I didn't give them
the fence at all I'm not letting them do
this to themselves I am not letting them
do this to themselves but I like that
hat she has it's sort of that hat with
the on the top with that look at the Fit
For A Minute look at the fit because the
fit is actually not bad at all by any
stretch the fit is not bad
now I hope this woman goes to heaven
soon because we have let her you could
get it away now but you we have let her
here's the problem we have led these
cities descend into chaos we have let
people destroy their lives with
narcotics because we feel like it is
compassionate to not arrest them force
them into treatment or put them in jail
and because we've decided that all the
problems in America
and there are some of them that
certainly come from inequality we know
that we're not dumb San Francisco is one
of the highest housing you know it's
crashing now but it's one of the most
expensive places to live and we know
that people can get forced into
homelessness because they're in a real
estate market that is pricing them out
and we know that and we're not saying
but we we also have to recognize that
the homeless problem in San Francisco is
not just a function of the rising cost
of housing it is a function of of
rampant drug use that has been
normalized in every part of the city
where people that are addicted to drugs
can do them in the street can buy them
in the street can turn tricks uh you
know with their bodies and buy drugs
immediately after
it's not simply just about wealth
inequality which is a great talking
point of people there's many other
things that are going into it
um it's an issue of policing it's an
issue frankly of what you will tolerate
as a city so I am saying at this point
now absent any other options going to
San Francisco and gawking at the people
whose lives have been destroyed by the
politics of that city is actually the
most Humane thing you can do it is the
most Humane thing you can do because
otherwise you are ignoring it and you're
not spending your money there
and even if you spend your money there
will it help not really but it's better
than not spending your money there they
need a tax base they need something they
need to give someone a blanket
so the reality is I know that it seems
cruel and heartless to suggest my course
of action which is to make San Francisco
a tourism hub for people that want to
just you know they're kind of bored and
they're and they want to go there and
they kind of want to be like oh my God
but I'm telling you right now it's
actually great it's actually the right
thing to do it's the right thing to do
um because it infuses the city with
capital
and and if we're not going to solve it
if we're not going to develop better
policies
um the only thing left to do truly truly
is to to to see it as a kind of a
haunted house like a screen Park to see
it as a little bit of a scream park and
to go and eat the good food and the
great quesadilla at El Farolito or the
great and then you comment you know and
then you're just like whoa look at that
whoa look at that one oh my God and I'm
telling you it actually helps